en el día del trabajador las calles del
mundo se llenaron en un contexto de
pandemia que transformó las economías en
la capital francesa la policía detuvo a
decenas de manifestantes en el marco de
una protesta convocada por sindicatos
que desencadenó en enfrentamientos con
las fuerzas de seguridad en berlín
también se produjeron altercados en una
manifestación en contra de los bajos
salarios
sí
en estambul la policía detuvo a más de
200 personas y dispersó a manifestantes
con gases lacrimógenos tan pronto como
los manifestantes empezaron a gritar al
principio de la manifestación la policía
vino y trató de impedir me grabar en
yale resistente entretanto en distintos
puntos de eeuu colectivos de migrantes
exigieron al gobierno de obeid en cesar
las deportaciones y otorgar la
ciudadanía a unos 11 millones de
ciudadanos indocumentados y recordaron
que son los hispanos la mayor fuerza de
trabajo en el país en la capital
mexicana unas 200 trabajadoras sexuales
rechazaron la violencia sexual y
exigieron condiciones de trabajo dignas
vemos que este gobierno
no importa ni el trabajo ni la salud
que nos está matando y que la única
manera es organizándonos para cambiar
todo y decirle a la gente que también
estamos organizadas
sindicatos de trabajadores marcharon en
caracas por mejores salarios y por un
plan nacional de vacunación contra el
hobbit 19 y en cuba se canceló por
segundo año consecutivo la marcha del
primero de mayo a causa del alza de
contagios de coronavirus las
tradicionales celebraciones
multitudinarias se cambiaron en esta
ocasión por pequeñas reuniones al aire
libre para conmemorar el día del
trabajador la festividad más importante
en el país después del aniversario de la
revolución